ici ils sont dans les campagnes dans les
villes que vous proposez comme
d'habitude c'est de la poudre de
perlimpinpin
cette semaine c'est le débat d'entre
deux tours entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen le match retour du débat
de 2017 et si on se faisait match aller
il ya cinq ans emmanuel macron et marine
le pen s'affrontent pour la première
fois dans le débat d'entre deux tours de
la présidentielle on est à quelques
jours du second tour marine le pen doit
rattraper son retard dans les sondages
et elle décide d'attaquer tout de suite
son adversaire sur macro et le candidat
de la mondialisation sauvage de
libéralisation de la précarité de la
brutalité sociale de la guerre de tous
contre tous deux du saccage économiques
notamment de nos grands groupes du
dépeçage de la france par les grands
intérêts économiques du communautarisme
et tout cela piloté par monsieur
hollande face à une marine le pen
ultra-offensive emmanuel macron reste
serein et tente de décrédibiliser les
propositions de son adversaire comme par
exemple la sortie de la zone euro sur
cette mesure marine le pen n'est pas
claire et s'emmêle un peu les pinceaux
donc vous proposer bien de sortir de
l'euro et non je vais négocier pour que
l'euro on s'en libère et on le
transforme en monnaie commune c'est ce
qui lève exister ce qu'il a il était
avant qu'il devienne la monnaie de la
france perd 1 avec de l'euro et les
choses soient très claires non on ne
paiera pas de le renverser avec biarrots
les banques centrales perron avec de
l'euro si elles le souhaitent marine le
pen est floue parfois confuses emmanuel
macron appuie là où ça fait mal vous
êtes en train de lire une fiche qui ne
correspond pas au dossier que vous avez
cités c'est triste pour vous parce que
ça montre votre impréparation à nos
concitoyens l'impréparation de marine le
pen c'est ce que beaucoup de français
ont retenu de ce débat qui marque un
tournant dans la campagne d'entre deux
tours de 2017 au final marine le pen
obtient que 33% des voix au second tour
ce débat lui a fait perdre en
crédibilité et elle mettra des années à
la retrouver
[Musique]